un país primero ilusionado con esta
visita como usted decía habían 20 años a
la espera y no solamente eso sino que es
una de las visitas sino las más
importantes que han dividido este país
desde la invasión norteamericana en 2003
y especialmente desde esa tristísima
sangrienta y mortífera guerra contra el
estado islámico que empecé tomó una
tercera parte de este país en 2014 y
duraron tres años hasta poder
recuperarlo elvira ambos sul se va a
encontrar con una población muy
agradecida pero también con unos muchos
problemas de seguridad muchos problemas
políticos aquí habrá elecciones en
octubre pasado como lo pidió unas
grandes protestas en 2019 cuando
especialmente a la juventud pidió
cambios que los políticos no han podido
verla y como usted decía una joven 19
que está cada vez más avanzada hay
nuevos casos están subiendo y por eso
estamos en toque de queda
este es el tercer en tercer fin de
semana donde la población iraquí no
puede salir a las calles
catalina por usted ya nos hace un perfil
de esta nación entonces en términos de
seguridad en qué país
en digamos entorno de seguridad cómo
está el país en este momento después de
una guerra contra el estado islámico y
además con la pandemia de kobe 19
mire la seguridad obviamente a pesar de
que vemos estos ataques a las bases con
presencia norteamericana y hablamos de
la milicia la seguridad es muchísimo
mejor de la que nos encontrábamos hasta
el 2017 siguen existiendo células del
estado islámico especialmente en esta
provincia de anbar muy cerca a la
frontera con siria que acaba de
sobrevolar el papá antes de aterrizar en
bagdad y siguen abriendo muchas células
y siguen habiendo operativos de allí que
la presencia también de esas fuerzas de
la coalición liderada por eeuu cuya las
milicias especialmente aquellas pro
iraníes se oponen y de ahí los
enfrentamientos hay una gran
preocupación por esa creciente poder de
esas milicias algunos de esos grupos son
bastante poderosos nos dicen que son más
poderosos que el mismo estado y ese
sería uno de los grandes retos de
seguridad que tendrían toda la población
iraquí también los cristianos como no lo
había dicho hace unos días el patriarca
de la iglesia caldea